just time for a visit to the big red
chair this is very exciting
okay first person in the red chair hello
hello what's your name
Celine hello Celine hi jack what story
have you got for us well this is my
second visit to the red chair actually
oh I was here 8 years ago right and I
told a story that I thought was really
good about when I was living in France
and something happened with my daughter
however a certain guest on the sofa that
night really did not like my story and
he was rather rude he actually said is
that the best story she could come up
with who does she bloody think she is
funnily enough my daughter met this
person at a nightclub recently oh my god
it's me
to actually watch him I sent you a
message didn't apologize I know I'm so
sorry
[Applause]
No
[Music]
you